[Music]
all right welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
anthony how many drinks are we in right
now only like five shots
he had damn rough night okay yeah get
cut the man a break
it was a tough uh it was a tough
yesterday but we don't have to get
inside no we don't have to
you know i mean rice 50 now what have
you guys been up to and
have you guys done anything you guys
wanted to do this year so far i did a
road trip up to uh a pch road trip i've
been wanting to do that for a while
because i haven't done this pch since i
was like
it's so nice [ __ ] 14.
how far did you go i went up to uh san
francisco airport
oh can you stay you stayed pch the whole
time or did you
like the european appreciation go on to
like the closer roads to the ocean
yeah i started from uh like santa
barbara and then i went up the pch
yeah who'd you go with uh my buddy
darian
and chris and josh yeah
every time i look at joe's stories he's
always doing some like outdoorsman [ __ ]
yes chopping wood he's in [ __ ] middle
of nowhere just like
sleeping actually the one that was hella
watching last time was when they were
pulling the [ __ ] in the metal
balls outside of the truck bro wait what
happened
okay so um you know my business partner
him and his
dad like they run the mushroom farm out
of the east coast and and then like
i guess i'm gonna say it now but they
got a spot in the west coast hey
yeah so like um they didn't have much
help at the time because they just were
rushing so they're like yo can you come
help and i'm like sure they're like it's
gonna be heavy and i'm like
well i don't know i i i used to work in
the warehouse like i haven't done manual
labor and i'm at the point now where
it's like been so long since i did
manual labor that
it's just fun now yeah i don't know how
it it's like
i feel you yeah it's like a one-off
project yeah yeah yeah
so it's it's different and i just like i
don't even only joe could find a phone
you know i could relate to that i like
helping my friends move you do yeah i'm
asking you next time i have a lot of
fun helping people move and then i don't
even like moving my stuff
i'm moving in july i got you bro i don't
even like moving myself dude
i'm kind of a connoisseur of it so i
feel like i take pride in that flights
of stairs too are you like a master of
like getting it up and down stairs
i don't i wouldn't say i'm a master but
i like the thought process of trying to
solve it and trying to get up there i
[ __ ] hate that
anthony's a hoarder too are you cool
with that well now i am yeah
just for just [ __ ] yeah you know what
i'm going to jump start let's continue
he's a horror too is that is it morally
okay
he's a [ __ ] we were pushing it but i'll
say yes i'll say yes so when the
the truck came late because there was
like they got a flat whatever we were
supposed to start at like
seven in the morning they didn't come
till like in the afternoon like noon
right
and you know i'm fasting so i don't
[ __ ] eat till like one
but when it came i was like all right
[ __ ] we better get
to it they opened up the back of the
truck
and i just see these massive [ __ ]
pipes dude
they're like there's no way you can lift
it by hand they're like plumbing pipes
they're like the size of uh like a like
they have big ones that are like maybe a
inch and a half thick and then they have
small ones that are maybe like half an
inch they're long as [ __ ]
so they they so so they're they're to
build greenhouses
so you know how like a greenhouse is a
huge hoop right
and so you have to bend this like it's
like a huge
it's like a huge tent basically yeah so
then
man it's probably you know how big a
[ __ ] semi is right like
the truck yeah it's like 40 feet long
yeah it's like so imagine this
is probably like 30 feet long [ __ ]
metal pieces
and then they have this forklift they're
trying to get it out they can't get it
out they're like [ __ ] man i didn't know
we i need
i needed two forklifts and i look at it
and i'm like there's no way we're gonna
[ __ ] finish this if you guys can't
get it out
let's snap that metal and do it by hand
so
cause they're in bundles yeah they're in
bundles so they started taking them out
like one by or two
so we were snapping the they're they're
combined
like with the metal belt so we have to
[ __ ] break through that
we take it out we would grab pipes like
about this thick
put it over our shoulder so there would
be a guy up just [ __ ] sliding pipes
down
and then guys would just be grabbing it
and then it just felt like we were like
dudes in a coal mine or some [ __ ] like
it felt fun yeah
but at the very end they're like you
know what we gotta use brains because we
got like
so every bundle will take about 30
minutes to finish and it's and it's
heavy [ __ ] right
so by the sixth hour or whatever we're
like all right we gotta figure out how
to get this
out seven o'clock
costume yeah available
i feel like a kid again everyone's like
what was your childhood
you were a child day laborer all of my
friends are like
[ __ ] just like me in a way where like
they're like in the middle of the work
they will get the forklift and then just
get somebody on it and hella break osha
laws and [ __ ]
and then someone's swinging on it will i
get back to [ __ ] work dude
and then um yeah but but at the end of
it all we were able to figure out how to
get the forklift to do it by using some
ancient technology
we got a [ __ ] stack of hay and a
[ __ ] big ass piece of uh
like a tree trunk and then we rolled it
out
and then finally we positioned it picked
it up like that
that was fun dude and there was a
celebratory moment in the ig stories i
saw that yo
after all that work we [ __ ] chopped
up some rib caps i made some skewers
yeah we had a bonfire [ __ ] cook those
up it was a great dinner
and they explained to you that what you
did had nothing to do with mushroom
farming
that's what i would love it's like hey
dude it's like you got to unload all
these vcrs they're like i guess this has
to do with mushrooms
[Laughter]
have you ever gotten to the point where
a lot of your work is so much
thinking that when you're just doing
physical labor yes
you don't really think yeah and it
actually becomes kind of fun
because you're outdoors you're moving
your body and you're like
i don't know it's different plus if it's
out of vengeance i'm in
because like nikki told me nikki told me
she's when we were moving into our place
right it was like three years ago
uh i was like i'm gonna move us and
she's like haha and i was like i will
[ __ ] move us yep until i'm dead
she laughed at you yeah especially when
you're significant if you ever want to
just motivate me bro just doubt me i
will [ __ ] do
it and i do all the work you're not
gonna help me with my crypto
[Laughter]
i'll give a million dollars
[Laughter]
i'll make you so [ __ ] rich you [ __ ]
the thing that pisses me off actually is
i felt that little ting little sparky
spark
cause i already am i'm already in the
middle of a revenge move with a with a
friend a long time friend
um who who uh who doubted you he doubted
me a little bit in crypto yeah and i'm
already
uh i'm well into the operation i bet
that's half of your motivation with
crypto i wake up every morning and think
about it it's just people like
being like steve you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about crypto's never
going to work
it's never going to come back and then
you're like all right
okay okay and he does the [ __ ] deep
dive yeah i call you crypto sensei but
you don't know i have 48 other sensei's
getting sweaty myself okay actually
don't burn your breath don't breathe
next one
sports one do you know what alchemics is
alchemy you're about to find out oh [ __ ]
you're about to you're about to be so
rich from this [ __ ]
you're about to be so rich right now i'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] so richard you're
gonna puke
you're gonna wish you never got this
rich before oh
[ __ ] a million dollars
[Laughter]
you were so right steve oh no i got
eight million dollars
i can't believe i pissed you off i'll
never do it again i'll do it again
tomorrow
[Laughter]
that'll be so funny it's like if nikki
knows that about you she's like
i bet you can't even do the dishes you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're like oh yeah
[ __ ]
she does it all the time yeah if you
guys move again are you gonna
move it yourself again or no [ __ ] no i'm
done
you know why you know why this [ __ ]
brought too many plants it's ridiculous
yeah you can't move a plant without
[ __ ] yourself up somehow or killing
it
well that too i put half the dirt out
the distribution of weight is so [ __ ]
up i'm like dude the way my back is no
way yeah but he's for sure moving the
hot tub
[Laughter]
hey you know just gotta deflate it first
and roll it up
you know what i think also i it's gotta
be
physical stuff that i see a future in
it's like oh
my friend's gonna make hella [ __ ]
money when i'm doing this
versus like yo can you come help me fix
my guard i'm like [ __ ] no
yeah yeah i agree with that you know
it's like yo can you
yo i need help like because um um i'm
understaffed i need somebody to come
over here and help me with my business
i'm like all right i got you
i'll come to the rescue it's different i
enjoy that
yeah i understand that today's video is
brought to you by audible
the last book that i listened to on
audible was the audiobook
written or it's a book written by my
friend bobby hundreds who wrote this is
not a t-shirt
but what i really enjoyed was listening
to the audiobook version
and the reason why is he actually
narrated the book himself
oh what so he read it yeah he have a
soothing voice he has a very soothing
voice but what i like about it is when
audio books are written
and or uh read by the author you get to
really hear the feeling and where
they're coming from so that you're not
filling in the blanks on yours on your
own you know
so that to me sometimes is even better
than reading a book
because you're really getting the
emotions the intent the tone
all of that from the author directly
which is better than just reading it off
of paper
yeah and i actually have uh
bobby's book because uh it was like in
this
giveaway package and and it's been
sitting on my shelf oh he's checking it
out yeah and a lot a lot of books do
like i do that like i buy books and then
i end up just
listening to the book because i finally
have time to getting around to it and
then
you know for me like books used to be
something that i would always read
yeah but now i don't have time to like
sit there and read something so like if
i'm driving and it's going to take me an
hour to get somewhere
audible is the way to go because you
cannot
read and drive i highly do not recommend
that
yeah even if you're born with more than
two eyes you still shouldn't even do not
meet and drive no so if you're looking
for other listening pressures they have
way more stuff than just audiobooks if
you go to audible plus
they have tv shows podcasts music
all that stuff so go ahead and check it
out go to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500 to sign up that's audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500-500
i have a buddy who's like he's super
loaded right he doesn't even need to
like work
anymore but he told me he loves to fry
chicken
at his restaurant that went so
i never in a million years would have
thought that's what he does like
yeah like he he he wants to sit there
and literally be in charge of frying
chicken
and he and he says he likes that and
working to register because
it's it's it's it's like um it's like
mindfulness meditation
one thing you just deal with one thing
over and over
over and over and helps them think that
makes sense actually yeah i like that
too though
but the register really you got to deal
with people it kind of breaks your
concentration from your own thoughts
doesn't it yeah but i mean
if you ever work the register it's
pretty routine like you know everything
on the menu they go can i have this okay
boom boom boom is that thank you
and you say the same over and over
there's random satisfaction of
collecting money
even if it's not your money oh yeah
collecting money for some reason
feels satisfying you put one in your
pocket one for the register one for the
pocket so does it hurt you when you give
change
you're like [ __ ] giving change is
different because you had to collect
something more to give less yeah so you
give me ten
and i'll give you three in his story and
breaking a roll of quarters always feels
like badass
yeah not pennies or dimes or whatever
but yeah
the big guns then putting the wrong
quarters in your pocket and
going to the high school dance you know
what i used to [ __ ] love
was cutting grass dude i love cutting
bread and grass
what i actually like to do is doing the
dishes i get like in a weird zone about
it
i like cleaning the house yo i my wife
is like you want me to help you i'm like
no
you leave the house you go go go to your
mom you want to come over
and i'm like i i have to get all this
stuff done and i have my routine
and she likes to help and i'm like you
don't [ __ ] help me
when i'm cleaning the house you know
bill gates washes the dishes every night
wait what that's his routine why does he
do that uh stupid
it's like um feels good after she's on
it's like
oh yeah this is the group that had that
dumb-ass story
about him going off on a weekend getaway
with that one check right it was ugly
anyways yeah
dude this one was like i'd rather do
bill gates
yeah yeah yeah dude was that a name
is it belinder or mullen melinda melinda
dude
you guys were thinking the same thing
yeah physical thing that i like right
now
you work work out bro literally for fun
casey was so bad he's like for fun you
love physicals so much you buy weights
yeah but not like like a like a job
thing i'm trying to think what's like a
thing that i like like oh yeah
my car washing the car unified
satisfaction and building your home gym
the way that you posted about how you
find satisfaction and building your home
gym
no i didn't i didn't like i i was like i
built my home gym
out of being frugal because i saw the
gym floor was going to be three g's i'm
like [ __ ]
that for a little one car space i'm like
obviously the same satisfaction as
helping somebody when it comes to like
helping them make
money doing it out of uh like i'm doing
it out
of god dammit i wish i could afford to
pay this you know what i mean it's not
because i want to do it
okay i think i started to feel that last
year when i was washing my bike washing
my car because i haven't washed my own
thing in such a long time
but there is a connection that you start
to have with your things when you
take care of it that way i watch it i go
this is why i always get a watch
[Laughter]
yeah i agree but it's it's weird
it's a new thing of mine i don't know
where it came from do you have a g-shock
yeah you like it very nice well i don't
know i only know what this is because of
joe rogan so
shut up nice you only know what a
g-shock watch is because i had no idea i
don't know about much about watches but
now i'm i'm learning as um
as um my all my friends get rich i'm
learning about not a rich one
but yeah it's a really good sports watch
yeah all around you could yeah it's the
best i remember when i was in high
school
everybody had g-shocks that was the
[ __ ] thing that's the thing huh the
different colors
the baby juice baby yeah g-shock's got
good street cred for uh every age
demographic
yeah i haven't seen people wear them
recently though everyone's on to apple
watches
i think g-shocks are tied really yeah i
mean apple watches
apple watches are cool they're just kind
of annoying though yeah i don't like how
it talks to me
so much yeah stand up [ __ ] take a
deep breath
kind not really everyone's like oh like
you know your friend so-and-so completed
the workout it's like i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] i i'm
trying to figure out a way to turn that
off
i don't know yet it's called get another
watch
true i just spent so much money on it
and i was like no i have to wear how
much is it
it was like seven thousand dollars i
think no i got it i got mine for like
200
something well that's a good deal
[Laughter]
this guy will be able to sell you [ __ ]
he probably moved to [ __ ] oklahoma
and tell you how awesome it is so then
you go there
dude i got you this cat texts me at like
six in the morning the other day and
he's like i just had prime rib for
breakfast and i'm like soul
right
except nikki's freaking like renovating
the house still
well that's to sell it bro um not the
value
yeah but we are enjoying it because
since we got the coleman dude
the hot tub that's tight life is
different now
so we just got a hot boujee a little bit
do you have a hot tub in vegas
not about dirt back there they don't
move
but i got i got prime rib for breakfast
for 25 bucks
we're at south point south
is that a city is that a [ __ ] 25
bucks i see signs that say like five
bucks
so that's what we're trying to get steak
and eggs it's not prime ribs
i know but i've never seen the prime rib
that's what i was trying to get and it
was uh it was so i was
six digging eggs you got to go to texas
station but it was uh
i want to go when i got there because
from from far away you don't see
the other part but when you get close
and you actually park
[Music]
how much do you want give me two scoops
of that spanish rice oh so you don't
have to serve yourself no more
it's like [ __ ] upgraded buffet yeah
it is that's kind of all the benefits
here it can make you
i'm headed i think already i don't want
to be judged at the buffet
yeah that's i think that's what's going
to hold people back wait what who judges
at a buffet
people serving if they're hot too you're
like oh i don't really eat much so um
as you're biting your lips
oh yeah i'm actually trying to work on
my core right now so i can't eat too
much
protein powder okay that's fine give me
the french fries you don't have protein
easy substitution i guess instead of two
scoops
just laying on me it's cheat day you
know yeah yeah i'm actually in a bulk
phase right now i'm actually trying to
put on some muscle
i gotta do my third workout in an hour
[Laughter]
realistically what's your favorite part
about living in vegas now
realistically um i can't even think of
it don't say taxes is gonna hurt
no no no no no no no that's uh so i
think like the taxes and like the
logistics part of it
like the logical things is what got me
there but the part that i like the most
is uh the super suburb family like
communal life that i was looking for
i found there oh because you couldn't
have that here it's hard to like have
play catch with their kid if there's
like three naked homeless men running
around like it's just it's different
right i don't really see your point but
yeah continue yeah but like so the park
the park that we that we go to almost
every night right now
at eight or nine pm it's still baseball
games going on
there's uh kids running around playing
like just i never see anything past
sunset
in l.a so we go there we're playing and
now the kids are all like meeting each
other
and um so that's really cool and another
part was this one kid
named jackson he kind of got lost and
the mom's like yeah asking the
uh sister hey do you see where jackson
is all the parents get up and they start
going jacks and jackson it's just like a
sense of community
whereas in la it's like this is my
family this is your family
another kid could be getting beat up i
don't give a [ __ ] because that's your
[ __ ]
you might sue me i don't know but over
there it's just the sense of community
in my neighborhood i'm like man this is
tight you could beat up all the kids
and the beautiful thing was they found
jackson face down in a ditch
he had been dead for 14 hours but they
found him together as a kid
he was trying to find some [ __ ] steak
and eggs just kidding he's chasing a
butterfly and he drowned
never had a chance you know yeah he's
like where's the little where's the five
dollar prime rib
one quarter inch of water face down
right now pete jackson did
yeah that's my favorite part it's like
the community small
town vibe but uh he never said
he never said what happened to jackson
that's what was it this guy he's trying
to reach all of us and he's like you
know when there was a missing child
um everyone was like hey where's the
missing child everybody search for it
and then yeah
and then he's like and then he's like oh
and i like i like planting in the
backyard and everyone's like
we found him we found him all right what
was he doing
he went to the bathroom on his own but
he didn't tell anybody that's dangerous
you can't go to the bathroom on your own
kids in vegas you think california would
never do that bro
they would never go to the bathroom by
this hell no because there's three naked
homeless people say they know that
exactly they have the street smart
[Laughter]
is real no matter where you are i don't
feel safe yeah like if it's nighttime
i'm like
no graffiti in the park wow no graffiti
no
carving in the toilet seat so they don't
have any culture out there yeah so they
don't know what their tagger name is you
know no
no no nobody has their own attacker name
the gangs don't have symbols yet yeah
this is [ __ ] or is it too new you
don't want to come out bro
no because summerlin's like 20 years old
now what i what i call it is
the b-roll life you know when you see
like movies the b-roll like
when you watch movies right and then
you're like where the [ __ ] are you going
to find a family throwing a frisbee with
like a golden retriever perfectly in the
background
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i lit
when i'm driving it feels like someone's
going
oh bart's coming all right background
action it's like the truman show yeah
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
another golden retriever you mean like
the pharmaceutical b-roll life
yeah yeah that one [ __ ] grandparents
just smile
wait so that's normal a fireman's
getting a cat from a tree
and then you drive by he [ __ ] dropped
it
[Laughter]
dead body he's like i'm sick of this
[ __ ] you may cause
anal bleeding true when you go outside
and like you're like in the northeast or
like
even utah when we're driving around i
was like what the [ __ ] this is like the
movies
and then but we live in a movie town
yeah it doesn't even feel anything like
that anymore we got park where we're
trying to break the ice and you know
yeah we were chasing [ __ ] seagulls
and [ __ ]
there's like yeah people are like
feeding ducks like bread like just
b-roll life [ __ ]
yeah dude there's no homeless people
taking the [ __ ]
yeah we're chasing birds we're trying to
we're trying to so this is in utah
yeah there was a big lake that was uh
frozen
and then there were just seagulls like a
[ __ ] thousand of them and me and mark
chased them like to go up like in a
michael bay movie like
okay that makes sense actually but then
we just ended up if there's a thousand
two annoying adults running across
frozen while the kids were trying to
feed them they we chased them all away
that's awesome you guys are hassle all
right
you